Wollen Sie, wenn Sie möglich kommen sollte, ausschließlich auf Rechtsradikale Inhalte beziehen oder sollen Sie auf alle illegalen Inhalte im Internet beziehen?
Im Prinzip gehen Sie auf alle illegalen Inhalte. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio. Ausgabe Chaosradio Express. Jetzt hätte ich mich schon fast wieder versprochen, wie beim letzten Mal, beim vorletzten Mal. Also hier ist Chaosradio Express, die 29. Ausgabe. Diesmal ein Podcast von den Datenspuren in Dresden. Datenspuren sind, ist die Veranstaltung vom Dresdner Chaos Computer Club, die einmal im Jahr stattfindet. Die sich Themen rund um Überwachung, Informationsfreiheit, Datenschutz im Allgemeinen zuwendet. Und hier sind einige interessante Vorträge heute schon zu hören gewesen. Heute am Samstag morgens noch mal ein zweiter Tag. Heute Abend gibt es eine nette Party mit Creative Commons Musik von zwei Netlabels aus Dresden. Elbklang und Phonecake. Ich hoffe, ich habe das jetzt richtig erinnert. Ich bin auch nicht alleine, sondern ich habe einen Gast bei mir, und zwar Alvar Freude, der hier auch morgen noch einen Vortrag halten wird. Hallo Alvar. Hallo Tim. Du hast heute deinen Workshop gemacht.
Ich habe heute und morgen einen Workshop. Also wir haben einen Workshop in zwei Teile aufgeteilt.
Okay, alles klar. Was war das Thema von dem Workshop?
Es geht darum, Ideen zu sammeln, wie ein Telemediengesetz aussehen soll, also wie die Internetgesetzgebung, die jetzt im Umbau wieder mal ist, wie das im Idealfall aussehen sollte, um auch die Interessen der Nutzer zu berücksichtigen.
Telemediengesetz ist was genau für ein Gesetz, um das nochmal kurz angesprochen zu haben?
Also es ist letztendlich die Internetgesetzgebung, die Gesetzgebung, die bestimmt, welche Rechte und Pflichtanbieter im Internet haben, welche Rechten und Pflichten Nutzer haben und so weiter. Und das wird irgendwann in nächster Zeit das Teledienstegesetz und den Mediedienststaatsvertrag ersetzen, die bisher die Säule der online Gesetzgebung in Deutschland gebildet haben. Und da sind einige Modernisierungen drin, aber auch einige Sachen, die nur aus den Alten übernommen wurden. Da gibt es einen Entwurf vom Bundeswirtschaftsministerium und da gibt es natürlich den einen oder anderen Punkt, wo man sagen kann, hey, das könnte ja mal ein bisschen ordentlicher gelöst sein. Wir brauchen zum Beispiel Lösungen, wie manche Probleme in Blogs oder in Foren oder mit Links umzugehen ist. Und da haben wir ein bisschen Brainstorming betrieben und Ideen gesammelt, wie denn solche Sachen aussehen könnten und sollten.
Ja, vielleicht können wir auf das Thema später auch nochmal zurückkommen. Vor allem hatte ich dich gebeten, hier im Chaosradio Express mitzumachen, um so ein bisschen deine Vergangenheit mal ein bisschen auszubereiten. Jetzt kommt die ganze Wahrheit raus. Dein Name war ja nun in den letzten Jahren immer wieder auf den Nachrichtentickern zu lesen. Das hatte verschiedene Gründe. Zum einen hast du ja diverse Projekte in den letzten Jahren durchgeführt, die sich rund um Informationsfreiheit und Rechte des Einzelnen im Internet gedreht haben. Und jetzt zuletzt, die letzte Meldung war ein Freispruch zu einem speziellen Fall. Das möchte ich aber jetzt ganz gerne mal von vorne aufrollen, damit wir uns da nicht vertun. Ja, wo fangen wir an? Mit deinem Namen verbindet man auch ein Projekt mit der schönen Abkürzung ODEM, O-D-I-M, was auch unter odem.org im Internet zu erreichen ist. Kannst du mal kurz vorstellen, was Sinn und Aufgabe von diesem Projekt war und ist?
Ja, also ODEM ist die Abkürzung für Online-Demonstration, was als Online-Plattform gegründet wurde, um Demonstrationen durchzuführen oder Protestbewegungen zu machen oder um netzspezifische Informationen zu transportieren, Aktivismus zu machen etc. Das war ursprünglich aus einer Semesterarbeit, während meines Studiums entstanden. Später wurde auch die Diplomarbeit von Dragan Espenssit und mir unter dem Label veröffentlicht und weitere Projekte. Die geplante Plattform für jeden nutzbare Plattform für Online-Demonstrationen ist bisher noch nicht realisiert worden können. Das ist natürlich auch immer mit Aufwand verbunden. Da gab es viele hochfliegende Pläne, aber es lässt sich natürlich nicht immer alles zeitlich so realisieren, wie man das gerne hätte. Vor allen Dingen, wenn man dann zwangsweise anders beschäftigt ist, was wir ja gleich noch dazu kommen werden.
Ja, aber es ist ja schon durchaus was dabei herausgekommen. Auf der Webseite findet sich auch die eine oder andere Dokumentation über das ein oder andere Projekt, was du angestrebt hast. Mit dem von dir schon erwähnten Dragan Espenshiet hast du ja, es stand, glaube ich, so ziemlich am Anfang der ganzen Entwicklung, ein Projekt gemacht, was bekannt ist unter dem Namen INSERT COIN. Ein, ich würde es mal sagen, ein experimenteller Netzfilter. Würdest du dem zustimmen dieser Bezeichnung?
Kann man so sagen, ja. Also INSERT COIN ist die Bezeichnung für unsere Diplomarbeit, die bestand aus dem theoretischen und dem praktischen Teil. Und der praktische Teil ist ein Experiment, was sich damit beschäftigt, wie Nutzer auf Manipulationen reagieren. Also wir haben einen Internetfilter entwickelt und betrieben, der alles, was die Nutzer an der Akademie, wo wir studiert haben, die Merzakademie in Stuttgart, alle Inhalte, die die Nutzer gesehen haben, wurden durch einen Filter gejagt und entsprechend manipuliert. Also wir hatten die volle Kontrolle über den Inhalt, was die anderen Mitstudenten und Dozenten, die in den Rechern arbeiten, wissen.
Also mit Inhalt meinen wir jetzt den Inhalt von Webseiten. Das war ein Filter, der sich wie ein Proxy zwischen Client und Server dazwischen gesteckt hat und die Leute haben im Prinzip das Internet benutzt, aber waren sich in dem Moment erst mal nicht bewusst, dass sie das quasi durch euer System hindurch getan haben.
Genau, wir haben uns auf Webseiten beschränkt, was aber da viele Menschen auch E-Mails über Webmailer lesen, natürlich auch darauf wieder Einfluss hat. Aber wir hatten uns grundsätzlich nur auf Webseiten beschränkt, was natürlich zum einen einfacher von der Realisierung ist und zum anderen auch einfach dem Konzept besser entsprach. Also man muss nicht gleich mit der großen Keule kommen, um so ein Experiment durchzuführen.
Ja, zumal zu dem Zeitpunkt ja wahrscheinlich auch im Web so im Wesentlichen auch noch die Wahrnehmung war, was das Internet so ist. Heute auch immer noch so. Ich würde sagen, es ändert sich schon. Also es kommen jetzt doch schon mehr Dienste wie Instant Messaging etc. mit dazu. Natürlich auch Peer-to-Peer-Netze, das haben die Leute mittlerweile natürlich schon begriffen. Aber von welchem Damals reden wir jetzt? Wann war Insert Coin rausgekommen?
Insert Coin startete im Sommer 2000 und dann sechs Monate. Also wir hatten glaube am 16. Januar 2001 die Diplomprüfung und in dem Zeitrahmen liefen die Sachen.
Und wo lief dieses System?
In Stuttgart, an der Märzakademie hatten wir studiert und da auch die Diplomarbeit gemacht. Ja, das war also zur Zeit als Napster gerade groß wurde und wieder einging, dann von Bertelsmann aufgekauft wurde etc. Damit hatten wir auch unsere Spielchen dann ein bisschen getrieben, da wir ja die volle Kontrolle über alle Inhalte hatten, die Leute über Webseiten anschauen.
Und was hat dieses Insert-Coin-System genau getan?
Also Insert-Coin selbst ist erstmal ein Proxy, der nicht die Daten speichert und durchleitet, sondern der die aktiv manipuliert. Anfangs hatten wir ein bisschen beobachtet, was schauen denn die Leute an, mit dem Ziel, später gezielte Manipulationen zu betreiben. Also wir hatten uns überlegt, oder wir hatten uns mehrere Fragen gestellt, die wir beantwortet haben wollen. Die erste Frage war, ist es überhaupt realistisch einen entsprechenden Filter zu entwickeln, der Webseiten in Echtzeit manipuliert? Das war uns im Vorfeld klar, natürlich. Das geht, weil wir auch gewisse Programmiererfahrungen hatten und so weiter. Die nächste wichtige Frage war, ja, merken die User das? Oder ab welchem Manipulationslevel merken sie es? Und die letzte Frage ist, wenn sie es dann merken, oder wenn sie es irgendwann mal erfahren, wie man es ihnen sagt, wie reagieren sie? Also beschweren sie sich kräftig, schlagen sie uns die Köpfe ein, was fällt euch ein? Ihr habt uns hier über mehrere Monate manipuliert. Oder wie auch immer. Oder vielleicht klappt es ja auch nur in einer Woche und dann fällt schon alles auf, fliegt alles auf und wir müssen das Projekt einstellen. Also das waren halt so die Fragen, die wir uns am Anfang gestellt haben. Und dann das auch im Hinblick darauf, wie man dann gesellschaftspolitische, welche Schlussfolgerungen man daraus ziehen kann. Wie man mit Filtersystemen umgeht, etc.
Und was war das Ergebnis? Also wie haben sie reagiert?
Also die Kurzfassung ist, dass der Filter über Monate lang unerkannt lief. Und er wurde nur durch einen Zufall aufgedeckt, nämlich unser Server ist ausgefallen. Hatten einen Hardware-Defekt. Und mit einmal gab es kein Internet mehr. Und die lieben Mitschüden sammelten sich, stapelten sich schon fast bei der Computer-Werkstatt, da haben sie beschwert, das Internet geht nicht. Und dann haben die Assistenten gesagt, ja, wieso, es geht doch. Und irgendwann, nach langen Suchen, kamen sie dahinter, dass es bei den Studentenrechern nicht ging. Und irgendwann haben wir es dann halt gemerkt.
Wie hatte dir denn überhaupt diesen Zugriff bekommen? Also ich meine, sich jetzt mal eben so in die Internetverbindung nach Hause einzuklinken.
Also man muss dazu sagen, von dem Projekt wussten nur unsere Professoren Oleg Aljalina und Dragan und ich was davon. Niemand anderes wusste was davon, auch nicht der Werkstattleiter von der Computerwerkstatt. Wir hatten lange diskutiert, wen wir einweihen sollten, aber es war uns wichtig, dass die Information möglichst geheim bleibt und nicht groß kursiert. Wo war ich stehen geblieben? Es wusste keiner.
Ja, es wusste keiner und bis zu dem Tag.
Wir waren an der Märzakademie, ich weiß nicht, wie es heute ist, hauptsächlich Max im Einsatz mit OS 8, 9, was auch immer. Das System hat keinerlei Schutz vor irgendwelchen Missbräuchen. Es gab zwar ein Login-System, was über den Server ging, etc., aber die Profile von den Browsern wurden von allen Usern die gleichen genutzt, mehr oder weniger. Die meisten haben ein Netzgeldprofil, manche haben ihr eigenes angelegt und wir haben mit dem kleinen Programm alle Netzgeldprofile auf der lokalen Platte gesucht und unseren Proxy eingetragen.
Also es war noch nicht mal so eine subtile Installation, die jetzt automatisch den ganzen Internet-Traffic zwangsweise durch den Proxy macht. Diese Zwangsproxys kamen ja später dann auch noch mal auf, sondern es war im Prinzip einfach nur voreingestellt, ohne dass die Leute das wussten.
Wir haben uns die tatsächlich einfachste Lösung in diesem Falle genommen. Wir hätten natürlich auch mit den entsprechenden Administratoren an der Akademie reden können und uns auf dem Gateway entsprechend einlisten und irgendwelche Firewall-Regeln zum Umbiegen vom Traffic oder sowas. War alles gar nicht notwendig. Wir haben die Proxys umgestellt und schon ging das gesamte Internet sozusagen für die meisten Teilnehmer über unseren Server. Damit konnten wir tun und lassen, was wir wollten.
Was habt ihr jetzt konkret gemacht? Was war die eigentliche Manipulation?
Wir hatten verschiedene Möglichkeiten, wie wir manipulieren. Die einfachste Manipulation, aber auch mit die wirkungsvollste, ist, dass wir beliebige Wörter durch andere Wörter austauschen konnten. Zum Beispiel das Wort Gerhard gegen Helmut und Schröder gegen Kohl und umgekehrt. Wir hatten ein sehr effizientes Verfahren, mit dem man fast ohne Zeitverlust beliebige Wörter austauschen kann. Für die Programmierer, das ist gegenüber Hashtables. Das war das Effektivste, weil dadurch kann man Massage schlagen. Das ging auf jeder Seite. Dann hat man gesagt, immer wird Helmut Kohl zu Gerhard Schröder, aber auch Helmut Karasek wird dann zu Gerhard Karasek.
Aber ich glaube, der schreibt sich mit TH, oder? Der Karasek? Ich weiß es jetzt nicht. Das ist auch egal. Auf jeden Fall, alle Helmuts mussten dran glauben. Und keiner hat sich beschwert. Bundeskanzler Gerhard Schröder damals schon...
Ja, wir haben sehr vorsichtig angefangen. Wir haben protokolliert, was die Leute anschauen, was die Studenten anschauen, anonym. Wir wollten natürlich niemanden überwachen. Es ging nur darum, Statistiken zu haben. Was wurde denn überhaupt angeschaut, damit wir Anhaltspunkte haben? Lohnt es sich, Spiegel online zu manipulieren? Oder lohnt es sich, GMX zu manipulieren? Oder was auch immer. Und dann, relativ am Anfang, hatte irgendjemand die Druckversion von einer Spiegel-online-Webseite aufgerufen, wo irgendwas von Gerhard Schröder stand. Und dann... Ach du schreck, Mist, da wird der Helmut Kohl draus. Und umgekehrt. Und dann haben wir gedacht, oh Scheiße, jetzt fliegt alles auf. Und waren ein bisschen vorsichtig und so weiter. Wir haben dann sogar beim Rumgehen in der Akademie irgendwo einen Ausdruck gefunden, wo gerade die Seite auch mit der Manipulation ausgedruckt wurde. Dann war dann das Ex-Bundeskanzler Gerhard Schröder seinem im Waren schreiben würde. Und... Wie sich dann ganz zum Schluss, als alles aufgedeckt wurde, rausgestellt hatte, hatte das ein Student tatsächlich gemerkt, dass da irgendwas faul war. Und hatte aber gedacht, na gut, da haben die bei Spiegel Online irgendeinen Fehler gemacht und irgendwas ging da schief. Und hatte sich das für seine private Kuriositätensammlung ausgedruckt.
Also letzten Endes, es gab keinen Widerstand sozusagen. Es hat sich keiner beschwert. Niemand stand mit der Brechstange vor der Tür und überhaupt haben sie alles einfach so hingenommen und es wurde auch nicht darüber geredet.
Es hat sich keiner beschwert, hat auch am Anfang keiner gemerkt, muss man sagen, außer dieser eine Student. Der hatte noch an ein paar anderen Stellen ein bisschen seine Zweifel, wie wir später mitgekriegt hatten.
Und was war die Statistik darüber, wie häufig hier was ausgetauscht wurde?
Ja, also wir haben am Anfang, wie gesagt, sehr langsam angefangen und dann sind wir später immer aufwändiger Manipulation gemacht. Wir haben irgendwelche Werbekästen bei GMX eingeblendet. Da gab es dann die angebliche International PayPal Association, wo man sich irgendwelche Brieffreunde raussuchen konnte und wo unterschwellig gesagt wurde, hier haben alle Free-Mail-Dienste persönliche Daten der Nutzer ausgetauscht, um den passenden PayPal. Zu finden. Wenn man bei Google oder bei allen damals üblichen Suchmaschinen irgendwas gesucht hatte, kam man auf eine von uns umgeleitete Seite, wo im Freien ein Hinweis drin stand, man möge doch bitte anstößige Webseiten melden. Wir hatten Werbeseiten eingeblendet, 3% aller Webseiten aufrufen wurden zu irgendwelchen obskuren Werbeseiten, umgeleitet etc. Da gab es viele verschiedene Manipulationen, die dann auch über das bloße Wort austauschen, hinausgehen, weil unser Filtersystem war in der Lage, auch komplexe Änderungen vorzunehmen. Also, die Sachen kann man auch unter odem.org-insert-coin nachlesen. Man kann auch den Filter noch ausprobieren, der ist immer noch aktiv, also wer ihn ausprobieren will. Einfach als Brauseinstellungen, proxy.odem.org, Port 7007, bei den Proxieinstellungen, und dann findet man die Hardcore-Variante. Wir haben, wie gesagt, in der Zeit immer weitere Filter gemacht. Irgendwann ist ja unser...
Ich wollte mal ein bisschen vorspulen, denn für dieses Projekt gibt es ja einen wesentlichen Preis. Das hat ja irgendwie ordentlich überschüttet worden. Da hat sich noch keiner beschwert, sozusagen.
Ja, also das Interessante ist ja, nachdem nach ein paar Monaten das aufgefallen ist, weil unser Server ausgefallen ist, haben wir das Bekannte geben, haben wir erklärt, für was das war, und haben eine Anleitung verfasst, wie man diesen Filter ausschalten kann. Nur das Interessante war, dass selbst drei Monate später immer noch auf ungefähr zwei Drittel aller Rechner dieser Filter aktiv war und niemand sich dafür aktiv interessiert hat, wie man ihn ausschalten kann.
Aber haben denn auch alle diese Informationen bekommen?
Die Mail ging an alle, wir haben Zettel verteilt und so weiter. Die Manipulationen, die wir durchgeführt haben, wurden immer extremer. Also teilweise waren manche Webseiten nicht mehr wirklich brauchbar.
Und trotzdem haben die Leute es nicht umgestellt?
Trotzdem wurde es wenigen Leuten bewusst, dass da überhaupt irgendwas passiert. Das für viele ist Internet Voodoo. Das ist wie Voodoo und dann passiert halt irgendwas. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ist. Ein Student kam mal ganz entgeistert zu uns oder zu Dragan und hat gesagt, ja, also ich habe gehört, ihr macht da irgendwas. Als das schon alles längst aufgeklärt war. Und Dragan hat sich schon gefreut, ja, endlich interessiert sich jemand hier für uns und fragt mal nach und beschwert sich vielleicht auch. Also ich mache hier eine Webseite, ich will mich für New Yorks Praxissemester bewerben. Und immer wenn ich die Lokal anschaue, ist alles richtig. Und dann sind da meine sexy Pictures und so. Aber wenn ich es online stelle, dann sehe ich immer boring Pictures, weil wir hatten sexy durch boring ausgetauscht als Wort. Und ja, was ist denn da? Und ich habe gehört, ihr macht es denn da? Ja, ja, ich wollte ihm mal auch einen Zettel geben, wie er es ausschalten kann. Hier sehen die in New York, das auch. Nein, das ist nur hier so, aber bei allen Webseiten, die du siehst. Ach so, dann ist es egal. Also tschüss dann. Dragan wollte ihm noch einen Zettel geben und hier so kann er es ausschalten, aber es hat ihn nicht weiter interessiert. Hauptsache, er konnte sich in New York bei der tollen Agentur fürs Parkesemester bewerben. Ich meine, das ist natürlich auch nachvollziehbar. Also in der Zwischenzeit ist uns klar, warum die Leute so reagieren. Klar, aber man erhofft natürlich trotzdem, dass da mehr Bewusstsein da ist und mehr Versuche, irgendwelche Hintergründe zu verstehen. Oder auch mal sich nicht selbst nur als dummes Opfer dastehen zu lassen. Auch zu sagen, okay, hier ist eine Information, wie ich manipuliert wurde, dann behebe ich es halt.
Jetzt kriegen wir hier von unten schon ein bisschen Konkurrenz von der eben gestarteten Party. Das dröhne ich etwas lauter rauf, als ich das jetzt mitgerechnet hatte. Okay, ich denke, den Teil haben wir ganz gut abgedeckt. Wie ich schon erwähnt habe, dafür gab es ja dann im Wesentlichen erstmal Preise und so richtig beschwert hat sich keiner. Das ist schon mal ganz interessant zu sehen, die Leute, man setzt ihnen einfach irgendwas vor und sie fressen es. Das kann man glaube ich so ein bisschen zusammenfassen. Jetzt hast du ja dann später auch noch weitere Projekte um Informationsfreiheit gestartet, aber da gab es dann nicht so gewünschte Ergebnisse. Das hat dann in insgesamt glaube ich zwei Anklagen, zwei Strafanzeigen geführt. Was war das erste Projekt, was da so aufgestoßen ist?
Es gab natürlich ein paar Folgeprojekte, die überspringen wir jetzt mal im kleineren Rahmen. Als dann 2001 immer mehr die Stimmung aufkam, insbesondere aus Nordrhein-Westfalen, man müsse doch irgendwelche ausländischen Webseiten, die jetzt nicht deutschen Gesetzen entsprechend filtern und aussperren, dann war das natürlich sehr passend zu unserem Thema der Diplomarbeit, weil der Theorie-Teil beschäftigt sich sehr intensiv damit, wie Filter funktionieren und ob man die einsetzen darf. Die Erfahrungen aus unserem eigenen Experiment kamen dann zu dem Schluss, dass Filter grundsätzlich abzulehnen sind. Da war natürlich klar, wenn jetzt die Diskussion über Internetfilter kommt, dann muss man da auch einschreitend irgendwas machen. Als dann in Nordrhein-Westfalen der Regierungspräsident in Düsseldorf, der für die Mehrenaufsicht zuständig ist, entsprechende Sperrverfügungen angedroht hatte, haben wir angefangen, die Sachen zu dokumentieren. Später sind die Sperrverfügungen tatsächlich ergangen und die Provider in Nordrhein-Westfalen...
Also die Sperrverfügungen wurden sozusagen von der NRW-Landesregierung an die Internet-Service-Provider...
Ja, von der Bezirksregierung, die von der Landesregierung beauftragt ist, quasi Mehrenaufsicht in Nordrhein-Westfalen zu betreiben. Und Medien ist ja Landessache. Und deswegen wurden die Provider angewiesen, also die in Nordrhein-Westfalen ansässigen Provider wurden angewiesen, zwei ausländische Webseiten von Neonazis waren es in diesem Falle zu sperren. Und die Begründung dazu war auch, wenn man das Milchtrinken verbieten will, dann muss man auch erst mit einer oder zwei Flaschen anfangen. Das ist das Originalzitat von dem Vizeregierungspräsident in Düsseldorf.
Ein Exempel statuieren.
Es ging einfach auch darum, politisch und technisch und gesellschaftlich auszuloten, ob das möglich ist und wie man damit umgehen soll, wie die Öffentlichkeit reagiert, was die Technik sagt. Und da waren sie dann, glaube ich, die lieben Verwaltungsbeamten doch etwas überrascht, dass der Gegenwind so stark war. Also die Provider haben sich sehr stark gewehrt. Und dann gab es hier Proteste, da Proteste. Wir hatten ja auch mit dem CCC und allen möglichen Organisationen in Düsseldorf eine Demo organisiert, alle zusammen. Und ja, da kam dann doch ein bisschen Gegenwind. Und das war, irgendwie hat man gemerkt, war eigentlich nicht so recht insgesamt. Weil eine gesellschaftspolitische Diskussion, wie man denn mit dem globalen Internet umgehen sollte, war nicht wirklich erwünscht, weil es war klar, was in Deutschland nicht publiziert werden darf, dürfe auch nicht empfangen werden.
Genau, es war im Prinzip noch eine extrem konservative Sicht auch auf das Medium Internet. Man hat es mit einem UKW-Sender verglichen, und was verboten ist, muss dann unterbunden werden. Und wenn aus diesem Internet was verboten ist, muss man das natürlich auch unterbinden. Sie haben immer geglaubt, man müsste nur irgendwo hinlaufen und da irgendwas einschalten. Irgendwie macht er die richtige Taste nicht gedrückt, weil das kann ja nicht sein, dass man so etwas nicht ausblenden kann. Aber das war dann sicherlich auch erst mal ein Lernprozess auf der Seite, zu verstehen, wie das Internet überhaupt funktioniert. Ich erinnere mich noch, da gab es verschiedene Diskussionen, wie so eine Sperrung gemacht werden soll. Filter ist ja sozusagen nur das eine Ding. Da geht man ja direkt in den Inhalt rein. Aber dann kam es ja dann auch mit, na ja, da muss man halt die Domains ausschalten, wo das ist, mit dem Problem, dass man natürlich unter Umständen auf einem Hoster, wo ganz viele Homepages untergebracht sind, sowas wie GeoCities, war ja damals noch extrem populär, wo dann eben unter GeoCities, slash Fuba, tra la la, 38, 49 stand halt irgendwie der Neonazi und zwei Zeichen geändert. Und dann hatte man halt einfach eine stinknormale Homepage von wem auch immer. Und das wurde natürlich dann alles auf einmal abgeschaltet, oder wäre alles auf einmal abgeschaltet worden. Also streckenweise ist sowas glaube ich auch probiert worden. Ich weiß es im Einzelnen nicht.
In der Schweiz gab es einen Fall mit GeoCities, wo wirklich die Provider angewiesen wurden, eine Webseite zu sperren, die bei GeoCities war, mit etwa 100.000 Millionen von von selbstseiten.
Haben sie es denn dann auch gemacht? Oder wurde wahrscheinlich gleich abgelehnt? Oder habt ihr sie noch alle?
Das ging in ein paar Wochen hin und her. Dann gab es da verschiedene Anordnungen. Irgendwann ist da auch der entsprechende Inhalt da verschwunden und woanders hin umgezogen. Das Interessante war, dass es ein Schweizer Staatsbürger ist, der Urheber der Inhalte, ein Schweizer Staatsbürger, wohnhaft in der Schweiz meines Wissens nach. Also eigentlich ist der Urheber greifbar, wo war er halt auch da in einem anderen Kanton und so Sachen. Also das sind alles immer so Sachen. Ich meine, für viele der Medienpolitiker, die vergleichen das Internet mit Rundfunk. Weil ich meine, man hat einen Computermonitor und das sieht so aus wie ein Fernseher und dann ist das irgendwie das Gleiche. Und dann, gut, man hat die Sender, ja wer ist der Sender? Na gut, der Sender ist dann für die Politiker der lokale Zugangsanbieter. Aber der ist ja eigentlich kein Sender, der ist nur die Vermittlungsstation was auch immer. Der Sender ist ja derjenige, der wirklich einen Inhalt bereitstellt. Und es würde keiner auf die Idee kommen, hier irgendwie einen Störsender aufzustellen, um irgendwelche Radiosender aus dem Ausland zu sperren. Aber im Internet war das halt so die Vorstellung, dass man da dann die Sachen blockieren könnte, weil man darf sie ja hier auch nicht ja hier nicht verbreiten direkt, also nicht selbst erstellen und verbreiten. Und das geht natürlich weit über irgendwelche Neonazi-Websites hinaus. Das ist halt ein Beispiel, wo man sagen kann, okay Neonazis, das hat jeder vernünftige Mensch, ist gegen Neonazis und dann muss man etwas tun. Ja, das ist ja eine vernünftige Sache, wenn man die sperrt. So sollte das verkauft werden. Und dann, ja, die Liste natürlich, was man alles sperren könnte, ist natürlich viel länger.
Jetzt bist du ja nicht durch deine eigenen Inhalte da ins Sperrfeuer geraten, sondern im Prinzip ging es um Links auf solche Inhalte. Was war jetzt der erste kritische Content, der bei dir angegangen wurde?
Ja, also, wir hatten ja Dokumentationen gemacht über diese Fälle und wir hatten die Webseiten benannt und auch verlinkt, um die es geht. Und mit der Zeit ist diese ganze Dokumentation gewachsen. Und dann kamen auch Kommentare und dies und jenes dazu. Und Beschreibungen und Hintergrundinformationen.
Also die Dokumentation zu welchem Projekt jetzt?
Zu der Sperrverfügung. Also es geht jetzt um die Sperrverfügungssachen. Und die ist in der Zwischenzeit relativ groß. Da gibt es auch Othöne von verschiedenen Anhörungen in Düsseldorf. Wo man dann sieht, wie sich auch dann die Herren, Beamten dann da schön widersprechen und so Sachen.
Das heißt, ihr habt im Prinzip unter anderem die Links zusammengetragen oder zumindest eine Auswahl von Links zusammengetragen von Sperrverfügung betroffenen Websites.
Am Anfang wurden die Provider mit vier Websiten konfrontiert. Die sie doch bitte freiwillig sperren sollten. Hat aber keiner gemacht.
Welche waren das?
Das ist einmal Hottencom. Das ist eine etwas geschmacklose US-Webseite.
Nicht im eigentlichen Sinne böse, aber definitiv etwas, wo man ein bisschen stärkere Nerven braucht. Ich kann euch das, liebe Jürger, wir empfehlen diesen Link nicht ausprobieren. Ich hab's euch gesagt.
front14.org, das ist nett. Das war eine US-Nazi-Webseite, die aber, als die Briefe raushingen, schon längst offline war. Und dann noch zwei echte Nazi-Seiten, nämlich Nazi-Laug. nazilaug.nsdap.org oder so was. Und stormfront.org. Nazi-Laug ist hauptsächlich deutschsprachig. Das ist ein ziemlich verrückter Kerl, da sieht man wirklich, das ist ein schönes Beispiel, wie sehr Nazi-Gedanken ein gutes Hirn zerfrisst, weil der Typ ist total durchgeknallt. Also aber im negativen Sinne. Und Stormfront, das ist halt so das Right-Right-Zeug, hauptsächlich englischsprachig. Und da an den Beispielen, an diesen beiden Webseiten, die sind nachher in der Schwerverfügung übrig geblieben. Rottenkomm ist rausgeflogen, weil Jürgen Büssow, der Regierungspräsident, sagte, ja, das nehmen wir erstmal raus. Weil es halt nicht so öffentlichkeitswirksam ist. Das ist nicht so deutlich. Wir nehmen erstmal die zwei Nazi-Seiten. Und dann wähnt er sich auf der sicheren Seite. Und klar, Medien, die sich nicht genäher mit der Thematik auseinandersetzen, bejahen natürlich erstmal, wenn jemand etwas gegen Nazis macht, eigentlich ja auch zu Recht. Und man muss sich sehr intensiv mit dem Thema beschäftigen, wenn man da was dran auszusetzen hat. Ja, und über die Sachen ist halt auch die Dokumentation bei Odem. Und das passte einigen Leuten halt nicht. Also es gab eine Strafanzeige dann gegen mich von einem Düsseldorfer Unternehmer.
Also von einer Privatperson.
Von einer Privatperson. Also einen Bezug zur Bezirksregierung kann ich nicht nachweisen. Weiß ich nicht, ob es den gibt. Und später gab es dann noch eine Strafanzeige von der Bezirksregierung gegenüber mir für ein anderes Projekt, das sich satirisch mit der Thematik auseinandersetzt. Das Freedom Phone heißt es in der Zwischenzeit. Damals hieß es noch Tele-Twasst. Und da geht es darum, dass wir einen Service anbieten, bei dem man sich beliebige Internetseiten am Telefon vorlesen kann. Auch irgendwelche Webseiten, die möglicherweise gesperrt sind. Und es gibt eine Top-7-Liste. Und in der Top-7-Liste rotieren immer irgendwelche Webseiten durch. Unter anderem die gesperrten Webseiten. Und da meinte die Bezirksregierung Düsseldorf, dass das ja ganz böse sei. Also Strafanzeige, Staatsanwaltschaft und Landeskriminalamt in Stuttgart ermittelten. Sehr lange. Irgendwann gab es dann eine Vorladung zur Polizei. Und ich habe mich beraten lassen und das alles gleich über Anwalt gemacht. Der Anwalt wurde dann angeschrieben vom Staatsanwalt. Und da wurde gesagt, ja, neben Einziehung der Tatmittel kommt auch ein Berufsverbot in Frage, etc. und Haftstrafe und so weiter. Also gleich die große Keule kam die Staatsanwaltschaft an. Und naja, das Endergebnis war Freispruch in allen Punkten, weil das Landgericht und das Oberlandesgericht Stuttgart dann beide zu dem Schluss kamen, dass das Linken in diesem konkreten Fall gerechtfertigt sei, weil es eine Dokumentation zum Zeitgeschehen ist, beziehungsweise im anderen Fall eine Satire. Und dann darf man diese Inhalte verbreiten.
In welchem Zeitraum sind diese einzelnen... Da hat es ja eine Weile hingezogen.
Das hat sich eine Weile hingezogen.
Wann ist dieses Freedom Phone... Also wann war die erste Anklage wegen der Links auf den Sperrverfügungen? Und wann kam diese Freedom Phone-Geschichte dazu?
Also die erste Strafanzeige war... Moment, das muss ich überlegen. Anfang 2002 oder Frühjahr 2002. Und die Strafanzeige der Bezirksregierung war im Sommer 2003, also über ein Jahr später. Und ich habe im Spätsommer 2013 zum ersten Mal davon erfahren. So lange hatte die Staatsanwaltschaft...
Auch von der ersten Geschichte.
Auch von der ersten Geschichte. Die haben da sehr lange ermittelt. Und es lag sehr lange am Landeskriminalamt rum. Und ich hatte ja auch Akteneinsicht. Da waren einige sehr interessante Briefwechsel zwischen Staatsanwaltschaft und Landeskriminalamt. Also die haben da umfangreiche Ermittlungen durchgeführt. Und irgendwann hat der Staatsanwalt...
Irgendwann konnten sie eure Webseite auch lesen, sozusagen. Ich frage mich, was man da jetzt ein Jahr lang drin recherchieren muss.
Ja, ein Halb letztendlich. Und durch die Strafanzeige der Bezirksregierung Düsseldorf oder einer Mitarbeiterin der Bezirksregierung Düsseldorf, aber auf offiziellem Briefpapier, ging es dann ein bisschen schneller. Also da, wo es dann bearbeitet. Und dann hat der Staatsanwalt, der Gruppenleiter Staatsschutz, halt dann ein bisschen intensiver bearbeitet. Und ja, hat dann halt so langsam mal eine Anklage gebastelt. Beziehungsweise erstmal diese, wie erwähnten, Drohungen.
Und was war jetzt die Kernaussage der Anklage? Also was wurde dir sozusagen konkret vorgeworfen auf Basis welchen Gesetzes?
Also, was meine konkrete Tat war, ich glaube, am Anfang hat der Staatsanwalt überhaupt nicht so konkret durchschaut, was da überhaupt passiert. Er ist nicht dumm, ich habe ihn ja nachher beim Gericht mehrfach kennengelernt. Aber ich glaube, er hat bei begrenzter Zeit, die man natürlich auch pro Fall zur Verfügung hat, hat er nicht ganz durchschaut, habe ich den Eindruck, was da vor sich ging. Aber letztendlich ging es um die Verbreitung von verfassungswidrigen Gedankengut, also materialverfassungswidrigen Organisationen, Symbole von verfassungsweislichen Organisationen.
Also quasi die Unterstellung, dass du diese Inhalte, auf die du ja nur gelingt hast, selber in das Netz gestellt hast.
Genau, also, dass ich die Inhalte verbreite, also Volksverhetzung, etc.
Genau, aber jetzt würde man gemeinhin unter Verbreiten verstehen, dass man selber die Inhalte in das Netz bringt und dafür sorgt, dass sie auf einem Server erreichbar sind. Aber das hast du ja definitiv nicht gemacht.
Genau, also ich habe ja eine Dokumentation über die Sperrverfügungsgeschichte gemacht. Und dabei, man muss natürlich die Inhalte, um die es geht, und um die Webseiten, um die es geht, muss man diskutieren können. Also habe ich die genannt. Und wie man es medientürisch im Internet macht, eben ein Link gesetzt. Also das ist eine ganz normale medientypische Aktion.
Das ist eigentlich auch eine journalistische Tätigkeit an der Stelle. Es war ja gar nicht mehr so Kunstprojekt, oder wir machen uns mal ein Fun draus, und hahaha, die sind die Links, sondern es ging ja schon darum, ganz konkret nachzuzeichnen. Das und das und das ist da jetzt passiert. Das ist sozusagen der politische Vorfall. Und wir möchten das gerne aufzeigen, niederschreiben, und dann macht man natürlich auch Links, ganz klar. Okay, das heißt, du warst jetzt im Prinzip angeklagt als Nazi.
Ich war im Prinzip angeklagt als Nazi, ja. Und das kam man irgendwann vors Amtsgericht. Der Staatsanwalt hat dann in der Zwischenzeit die Sachen mit Berufsverbot etc. fallen lassen. Es war ihm dann doch ein bisschen zu heiß, als er da mal ein bisschen näher nachgeschaut hat. Und beim Amtsgericht kam es immerhin trotzdem zu einer Verurteilung. Die Richterin hat dem Staatsanwalt zugestimmt, dass das eine Verbreitung der Inhalte sei durch den Link. Und zudem sei es keine Dokumentation zum Zeitgeschehen. Der ist ein Projekt und das andere Projekt sei, das für jeden von uns sei keine Satire. Und damit dient es nicht privilegierten Zwecken. Denn bei rechtsextremistischen Sachen ist es so, dass man zum Beispiel Hakenkreuz zur Dokumentation zum Zeitgeschehen zeigen darf oder zur Bildung, zur Forschung etc. Sonst könnte in keinem Schulbuch irgendwelche Hakenkreuze abgebildet sein. Oder irgendwelche Hitlerreden wären nicht möglich etc. Also da gibt es diverse Ausnahmen, die natürlich auch alle letztendlich auf Artikel 5 Grundgesetz der Meinungsfreiheit beruhen, in welchem Kontext man mit solchen Inhalten auch umgehen darf. Und die Richterin sah das halt nicht als ergeben an und den Link pauschal als Verbreitung. Und daraufhin bin ich selbstverständlich in Berufung gegangen, beim Landgericht. Übrigens der Staatsanwalt ist auch in Berufe gegangen, weil ihm das Urteil nicht hoch genug war.
Jetzt muss ich nochmal fragen, also diese Amtsgerichtverurteilung bezog sich auf die erste oder auf die zweite Anklage?
Auf beide zusammen. Also die wurden beide zusammengeführt.
Okay, weil man dachte, du bist eh so ein Triebtäter, irgendwie kannst du gar nicht genug davon kriegen. Irgendwie hast du jetzt auf ganz vielen Webseiten irgendwo deine Links platziert. Und das wurde generell alles immer gemeinsam behandelt.
Es ist auch üblich so, dass man solche Verfahren, die irgendwie zusammengehören, auch zusammenlegt. Das bearbeitet dann einen Staatsanwalt.
Also das Amtsgericht meinte halt, irgendwie du wärst böse und dann kamst du zum Landgericht und die waren dann schon andere Auffassung.
Genau, das Amtsgericht meinte, ich wäre böse und vor allen Dingen, weil ich nicht einsichtig sei, sei es besonders schlimm. Weil wenn man natürlich einsichtig ist, dass man vielleicht ja doch einen Fehler gemacht hat, gibt es eine mildere Strafe. Aber wenn man darauf beharrt, dass man Recht hätte, dann wird man extra noch ein bisschen was drauf. Beim Landgericht sah es dann schon ein bisschen anders aus. Oder komplett anders, denn das Landgericht hat die Entscheidung vom Amtsgericht komplett aufgehoben. Hat auch gesagt, es ist schon mal fraglich, ob ein Link überhaupt ein Verbreiten oder Zugänglichmachen darstellt. Zumindest in der mündlichen Begründung. Aber das war nicht mehr relevant, weil selbst wenn es verbreitet würde, wäre es in diesem Kontext laut Landgericht Stuttgart vollkommen legal. So wie ich das gemacht habe. Weil es eine Dokumentation zum Zeitgeschehen ist. Das Odem-Org, die Dokumentation. Und das Freedom-Forum eine Satire sei. Und dadurch sei es dient des beides privilegierten Zeugens.
Aus beiden Gründen. Also sowohl die satirische Nutzung als auch die dokumentatorische Nutzung wurde dann entsprechend gewürdigt.
Genau. Also es nennt sich Sozial-Adäquats-Klausel, der Unterparagraf. Weil es sozial-adäquat ist, wie diese Inhalte verbreitet werden. Und zu rotten kommen, hat da auch explizites Gericht gesagt, das sei keine Gewaltdarstellung. Das ist eine Art juristische Details.
Warum?
Ich weiß, weil es keine lebendigen Personen sind etc. Auf jeden Fall Freistbruch in allen Punkten.
Und dann ist aber nochmal die Staatsanwaltschaft in Berufung gegangen.
Also in der Zwischenzeit ist mir auch klar, was die Motivation der Staatsanwaltschaft ist. Also in Stuttgart allgemein vermutlich haben die auch eine Weisung, entweder vom Oberstaatsanwalt oder vom Justizministerium. Sind sie dabei, generell gegen jegliche Darstellung von Nazi-Symbolen vorzugehen. Und zwar ist die Philosophie, die sie vertreten, dass man aus dem öffentlichen Bewusstsein die Wahrnehmung von Hakenkreuzen verbannen möchte. Also ein bisschen durch die Medien ging das auch.
Aus den Augen, aus dem Sinn.
Ja, so kann man das im Prinzip sehen. Also es ging ein bisschen durch die Medien, dass die Staatsanwaltschaft Stuttgart Studenten oder Punks Anklag, die so einen Aufnäher mit einem durchgestrichenen Hakenkreuz haben, also dieses Parken verboten quasi, mit einem Hakenkreuz als Ausdruck, ich bin gegen Nazis. Und das verfolgen die und zwar wegen Verbreitung verfassungswidriger Symbole. Und ich hatte eine längere Diskussion in der Pause beim Landgericht bevor der Urteilsvergründung mit dem Staatsanwalt. Und ja, er ist halt der Ansicht, dass man diese Symbole nicht weiter zeigen soll. Und dass das einen Gewöhnungseffekt möchte er vorbeugen. Und deswegen soll das aus möglichst vielen, aus öffentlichen Wahrnehmung verschwinden. Und das ist halt auch die gesamte Linie der Staatsanwaltschaft in Stuttgart. Die haben zum Beispiel einen Versandhandel namens Nixgut. Das gesamte Material beschlagnahmt und jetzt auch angeklagt, den verantwortlichen Leuten. Auch wegen verbreitensverfassungswidriger, oder verkennzeichnet verfassungswidriger Organisationen. Und interessanterweise hat übrigens das Landgericht, das ist mein aktueller Stand, das Landgericht Stuttgart die Anklage abgelehnt, weil es schon vor der Verhandlung überzeugt ist, dass das kein Straftatbestand sei. Und dagegen ist jetzt die Staatsanwaltschaft wieder irgendwie rechtlich vorgegangen. Also es geht da ein bisschen rund und die versuchen es halt auch auf verschiedene Arten. Und sind ja auch in meinem Fall ein bisschen Oberlandesgericht gegangen. Und dann noch mal eine juristische Prüfung.
Okay, das ist jetzt sozusagen der zweite Schritt. Also nachdem sie jetzt einmal gewonnen, einmal verloren haben. Oberlandesgericht und die sind dann zu welchem Ergebnis gekommen?
Das Oberlandesgericht kam zu dem Ergebnis, dass eine Verlinkung, nach der Meinung des Oberlandesgerichts, Schuttgart, zwar grundsätzlich eine Verbreitung der verlinkten Seiten und aller Unterseiten sei, aber dass in diesem konkreten Falle das Straf frei bleibt, weil es in dem entsprechenden Kontext einer Dokumentation bzw. einer Satire stattgefunden hat. Also innerhalb des Kontext einer Dokumentation darf ich diese Inhalte verbreiten. Und als Satire darf ich die auch verbreiten, weil es um die Kunstfreiheit und ähnliche Sachen geht.
Aber wenn man zum Beispiel jetzt einfach in seinem Webblog einfach nur seine Meinung äußern würde und dann darauf linkt, dann würde man im Prinzip schon wieder eins auf die Finger kriegen. Das ist doch eigentlich das, was Sie uns sagen wollen.
So hat das Gericht dargestellt, dass ein Link grundsätzlich eine Verbreitung darstellt. Und das ist sicherlich eine Sache, die man so nicht teilen kann. Der Hintergrund ist natürlich auch klar, was die verhindern wollen. Die wollen nicht, dass irgendein schlauer Nazi, der halt ein bisschen mehr IQ hat als seine Kollegen, auf die tolle Idee kommt, eine Webseite aufzumachen, wo die Links zu den ganz hardcore Jungs aus den USA sind und dann straffrei bleibt. Das ist doch die Horrorvorstellung. Da könnte ja einer jetzt diese Lücke nutzen und einen Link setzen. Ein Link könnte ja im Internet setzen und ich meine, als ob die betreffenden Leute nicht selbst gleich auf die Webseite könnten oder nicht jemand anderes in den USA eine Webseite mit den Links machen könnte. Also das ist einfach so die Angst, da könnte ja jemand irgendetwas missbrauchen.
Gab es eine Diskussion darum, was jetzt als Link gilt? Also ist es sozusagen schon ausreichend, nur die URL zu nennen? Oder muss das dann auch wirklich als Hyperlink im entsprechenden HTML-Markup so zum Anklicken markiert sein?
Also das wurde jetzt vom Gericht nicht ausdrücklich irgendwie gesagt.
Aber bei dir waren es eigentlich immer Anklickbare Links.
Es waren Anklickbare Links, ja. Aber es wurde vom Gericht nicht näher betrachtet. Auch die gesamte Link-Problematik wurde nur sehr oberflächlich behandelt. Also es ist schon halt dran, ja, es ist halt ein Verbreiten und fertig so, jetzt mal nach dem Motto. Aber aus der Diskussion mit dem Staatsanwalt weiß ich, dass er explizit jetzt offengelassen hat, was er machen würde, wenn es denn kein Link wäre. Also noch beim Amtsgericht hatten einige der anwesenden Gäste und Journalisten mit ihm da ausführlich geredet und da wollte er sich nicht darauf festlegen, wie er es denn handhaben würde, wenn es nur die URL ist. Also er hat es nicht ausgeschlossen momentan. Ich meine, es ist natürlich auch konsequent, weil je nach Browser, je nach Plugins, was man hat, braucht man es trotzdem nur anklicken. Und markiere ich es halt, mache ich einen Doppelklick oder einen Dreifachklick drauf und kopiere es und habe es in der Adresseile genauso schnell. Also der Unterschied ist marginal.
Aber dann könnte man halt auch sagen, ich schreibe das jetzt hin, so, ja, webseite.com, so wie man das ja heute auch schon bei E-Mail macht, um sozusagen den Spamern es nicht zu einfach zu machen, dass man dann quasi so in ganzen Worten ausschreibt, dann wäre das dann halt auch schon wieder eine hanebüchende Diskussion, ob man sowas jetzt auch wirklich als Link werden kann.
Ja, da kann man sehr fein dann die Sachen aufzisalieren. Auch das ja heißt, ja auch die Unterseiten, so ein Strafbar. Ja, in welchem Level geht das?
Genau, was ist, wenn ich jetzt auf geocities.com linke, heißt das, dass es alle Homepages von allen Leuten ist?
Angenommen, meine Dokumentation wäre jetzt nicht als Dokumentation durchgegangen und das Gericht hätte festgestellt, ja ich bin ein böser Nazi, trotz langer Haare und sei zu verurteilen. Ja, was ist denn mit denjenigen, die über mich berichtet haben und über den Fall berichtet haben und auf meine Webseite gelingt haben? Also es ist dann ja auch eine Unterseite und ein Weiterverweis. Also ab welchem Level gilt das dann nicht?
Ich grübel schon, ob wir jetzt diese Chaosradio Express Sendung als Dokumentation oder als Satire kennzeichnen sollen. Vielleicht sollten wir noch ein paar doofe Witze machen. Ist denn jetzt die gerichtliche Auseinandersetzung vorbei? Es ist vorbei. Also es gibt keine Berufungsmöglichkeit mehr. Die Sache ist ausgestanden für dich zumindest jetzt. Aber im Prinzip ist ja so ein farler Beigeschmack bleibt ja dabei über. Wie war denn nochmal die Formulierung in diesem konkreten Fall?
Die ganz konkrete Formulierung, weil hier ist es nicht aushändig, aber die Aussage ist, dass ein Link grundsätzlich als Verbreitung der verlinkten Inhalte gilt nach.
Okay, einerseits aber warum bei dir dann nicht?
Und alle Unterseiten, wohlgemerkt. Bei mir gilt das auch, aber es bleibt trotzdem straffrei, weil diese Links und damit die Unterseiten Bestandteil einer größeren Dokumentation zum Zeitgeschehen sind und einer Satire. Und da die Dokumentation, wie hat das Gericht es gesagt, beeindruckend umfangreich sei und außerdem wahrheitsgemäß sei und objektiv korrekt etc., deswegen ist es straffrei.
Jetzt weiß ich wieder, welche Formulierung ich meinte. Es sei in einem beeindruckenden Kontext.
Ja, so hat das Gericht das festgestellt.
Das heißt, man muss sozusagen nur dafür sorgen, dass die Webseite auch beeindruckend ist, die man da schafft.
Ja gut, also aus Blickwinkel des Gerichts reicht es beeindruckend ja nicht aus, sondern es muss inhaltlich beeindruckend sein. Also es muss ein strafbefreiender oder privilegierender Tatbestand da sein. Also es ist wie, wenn man jetzt hier irgendwie Nazimaterialien verteilt, dann darf man das auch nicht. Aber in einem gewissen Kontext darf man es dann wieder. Also in einem Schulbuch darf man Hitlerreden abbilden, auch wenn er da volksverhetzende Aussagen tätigt. Aber da jetzt auf der Straße ein Plakat hinhängen darf man nicht. Und es ist natürlich die Frage, ab welchem Kontext gilt es als Dokumentation zum Zeitgeschehen? Daher ist natürlich die Angst, dass irgendwelche Rechtsextremisten auch ihre eigene Dokumentation machen, die dann sich vielleicht nicht so an die Wahrheit hält. Und so versuchen, irgendwelche Lücken zu nutzen, um ihre Ideologie zu verbreiten. Das ist immer so die Angst im Hinterkopf, dass man da irgendwelche Lücken haben könnte. Wie man es sich manchmal bei manchen Programmierern mehr wünschen würde, die mehr Angst über Sicherheitslücken haben, wenn sie irgendwelche Sachen programmieren, so ist es da bei Juristen, dass sie Angst haben, jemand könnte raus.
Ich finde es insofern auch bemerkenswert, dass es zu dieser Sache überhaupt gekommen ist, weil es gab ja schon 1997 diesen Fall von Angela Marquardt, damals noch etwas bekanntere Politikerin der PDS-Klub, mittlerweile ist sie da nicht mehr. Und sie hatte damals einen Link auf die Zeitschrift Radikal hinterlegt, das ist so eine linksradikale Zeitschrift, die halt ein digitales Archiv hatte auf einem Web-Server. Und interessanterweise lag dieser Web-Server in Holland bei Axis for All. Und auch dafür wurde sie ja angegangen. Und auch davon wurde sie dann letztlich freigesprochen, weil auch da, ich glaube, bei der ersten Verhandlung war das halt auch überhaupt so. Andy war ja da auch geladen als Experte und hat ihm dann erstmal klargemacht, dass ja hier irgendwie sie ja alle erstmal gar nicht wissen, wovon sie eigentlich reden. Und wissen sie überhaupt, was ein Hyperlink ist. Und dann wurde das erstmal ganz schnell vertagt.
Und dann kann ich mir gut vorstellen, wie dann das Gericht dann reagiert. Weil die sind natürlich sehr schnell sehr sauer, wenn man ihnen sagt, sie haben keine Ahnung.
Er hat das glaube ich schon etwas eleganter formuliert.
1997 war das auch noch ein bisschen was anderes. Da hatten sie ja wirklich noch weniger Ahnung.
Da hatte halt auch einfach irgendeine Ahnung. Das hat man auch gemerkt in diesen ersten Internetjahren, da hatte dieses ganze juristische System, war komplett von links überrannt. Die wussten eigentlich überhaupt nicht, was auf einmal los ist.
Aber heutzutage denken sie ja, sie wüssten alles. Sie waren schon mal im Internet, haben es mal geschafft, eine E-Mail zu schreiben oder gucken vielleicht jeden zweiten Tag bei Spiegel online nach. Viele Menschen halten sich für sehr kompetent und denken, ein Link, da klicke ich drauf und dann bin ich sofort auf der anderen Webseite. Mit nur einem Klick komme ich da und dahin. Ich glaube, auch bei dem Marquardt-Fall lief das dann auch nicht auf irgendwelche Linkbefreiungen raus, also dass der Link nicht strafbewehrt wäre, sondern es lief daraus hinaus, dass sie keine Kenntnis hatte, dass die Inhalte zu dem Zeitpunkt später mal strafbar waren, weil es waren ja nicht alle Ausgaben der Radikalen, meines Wissens, indiziert, sondern nur zwei Ausgaben, die sich da mit diesen Bahnenmanipulationen beschäftigt hatten und da sich die Inhalte dieser Webseite geändert hatten, die Marquardt verlinkt hatte, war sie nicht mehr dafür verantwortlich. Wenn aber die Inhalte schon da gewesen wären, als sie den Link gesetzt hatte, dann wäre es vielleicht anders.
Ja, wobei da wird es natürlich auch echt knifflig, weil erstmal, wer kann wirklich zuverlässig nachweisen, dass ein Link zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt da war und dass er dauerhaft da war und vor allem, wer, ich meine, ich habe auch noch diverse alte Webseiten, wo ich dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die liegen noch irgendwo rum, vielleicht noch bei irgendeiner alten Firma unter Tilde mein Name, hast du nicht gesehen, oder in der Uni hat man auch irgendwas und man hat es gar nicht so im Kopf, linkt irgendwo hin und mittlerweile ist da einfach ein ganz anderer Inhalt, weil auch schon die Domain gar nicht mehr demselben Besitzer gehört. Domains wandeln ja schnell durch die Gegend. Hier auch diese Front 14 Org, die du da mit in deiner Linkliste drin hattest, hat sie jetzt einen Domain-Grabber geschnappt. Da ist jetzt derzeit dieser übliche Portalspaß. Aber könnte ja morgen auch schon wieder was ganz anderes da stehen. So und es ist wirklich aberwitzig. Und ich denke, man muss da auch einfach mit der Realität leben, dass Links ganz normale Schmiermittel des Internets sind. Und über kurz oder lang muss es natürlich auch mal die gerichtliche Seite durchsehen. Es gibt noch einen anderen schönen Fall, schöne Formulierung, einen unschönen Fall auch Heise, die ja nun wirklich auch seit langer Zeit sich in diesem Themenbereich mit engagieren, sind vom Hamburger Landgericht dafür verdonnert worden, dass sie irgendwie in ihrem Forum auch für Links und Beiträge, also auch Inhalte in dem Moment, verantwortlich sind. Und ihnen wird dann halt zugemutet und damit natürlich jetzt auch allen Forumbetreibern, dass man permanent den Überblick hat über alles, was da gepostet wird. Also quasi bin ich der Eigentümer einer Domain, dann muss ich mir jedes Beit anschauen. Oder wenn ich es nicht tue, dann kann ich gleich verklagt werden.
Ja, also bei Heisegittezweifel ist ein eines dieser Linkgeschichte mit der Musikindustrie und dem Kopierschutzgeschichte.
Richtig.
Und das andere ist dieses unsägliche Forumsurteil, wobei man auch hier sagen muss, es ist ein ganz spezieller Fall, wo sich das Gericht ausschließlich auf Presserecht bezog und ausschließlich auf diesen konkreten Fall. Trotzdem hat es schon längst dazu geführt, dass bevor überhaupt die schriftliche Begründung von dem Hamburger Landgericht vorlag, andere Forenbetreiber Abmahnungen mit Hinweis auf dieses Urteil bekommen haben. Also bevor überhaupt klar war, was denn jetzt die Entscheidungsgründe für das Gericht waren. Aber obwohl es jetzt auch hier in einem sehr speziellen Fall ist, ist es meines Erachtens einfach falsch, weil das Gericht hat gesagt, dass ein Forenbetreiber nicht nur irgendwelche Inhalte, die Rechte anderer Verletzen entfernen muss, wenn er darauf hingewiesen wird, sondern dass er auch eine entsprechende Abmahnung, dass solche Forenbeiträge in Zukunft nicht mehr erscheinen dürfen, akzeptieren muss. Demnach müsste Heise dann dafür sorgen, dass in ihren Foren eine ähnliche der betreffenden Verletzungen nicht mehr auftritt. Also sie müssten im Prinzip das ganze Forum...
Davon hatten sie doch schon Kenntnis.
Ja, sie müssten das gesamte Forum überwachen und herausfinden, ab wann hier dieses eine Programm erwähnt wird, um was es da ging. Ich meine, das ist sowieso eine ganz seltsame Geschichte mit dem...
So eine gute Arbeitsbeschaffungsmaßnahme für Bagatelljuristen.
Ja, letztendlich ging es auch um jemand, der eine sehr zweifelhafte Geschäftsmethode hat. Und wo im Forum aufgerufen wurde, ihn ein bisschen zu ärgern, um es mal ein bisschen kurz zu sagen. Und das hat ihm nicht gepasst. Und diesen Aufruf möchte er in Zukunft präventiv verhindern. Obwohl er auch kein weiteres Mal entstanden ist, also nicht mehr aufgetaucht ist, hat er eine entsprechende Abmahnung verschickt. Und das Gericht sah es als korrekt an, außerdem sind der Foren, wie das Gericht sage, sowieso eine besonders gefährliche Einrichtung. Und da müsste man besonders aufpassen.
Ah, die Formulierung haben sie so genutzt? Gefährlich?
Das müsste hier in dem Artikel drin stehen.
Wir klicken mal ein bisschen hier.
Besonders gefährliche Einrichtung.
Eine besonders gefährliche Einrichtung. Und was ist da mit Mailinglistenarchiven? Wenn ich mir die Flame Wars da anschaue und was da nicht alles... Also das ist halt auch das Ding. Also Webforen, letzten Endes reden wir ja eigentlich immer nur von Webseiten, vollkommen unabhängig davon, wie sich dieser Inhalt dieser Webseite füllt. Und es ist ja da gar kein Ende in Sicht. Also ich halte das für eine sehr bedenkliche Entwicklung, in der man auf jeden Fall da nochmal was entgegenhalten muss, wenn man die Möglichkeit hat.
Ja, also es geht ja hier auch darum, dass Heise für Beiträge anderer Leute verantwortlich gemacht werden soll. Es geht ja nicht darum, dass Heise nicht mehr irgendetwas schreiben soll. Da kann man sich natürlich auch überstreichen.
Das ist ja auch beim Mailing-Listenarchiv genau das gleiche Ding. Weil wenn halt irgendjemand was in seiner Mail schreibt, dann muss man halt erstmal dafür sorgen, dass dann die Mail, ja, was rausgenommen wird aus dem Mailing-Listenarchiv. Oder soll man die dann zensieren?
Ja, auch unter welchen Bedingungen.
Ja, und wer liest alle seine Mailing-Listen?
Unter welchen Begründungen soll etwas herausgenommen werden? Das sind natürlich alles sehr schwierige Fragen. Da haben wir auch vorhin, als wir ein bisschen uns Gedanken gemacht haben im Workshop, wie denn ein Telemediengesetz aussehen sollte, oder wie wir uns das dann wünschen, sehr lange diskutiert. Ich meine, es gibt natürlich immer zwei Seiten. Einmal derjenige, der eventuell geschädigt wurde, oder der geschädigt wurde, und dann der andere, der dann der Betreiber von irgendeiner Webseite ist. Das ist natürlich nicht so einfach. Aber dann hier präventive Prüfpflichten dem Betreiber aufzulegen, das widerspricht komplett der bisherigen Rechtsprechung und auch komplett dem Teledienstegesetz. Wobei sich das Gericht hier aufs Presserecht bezogen hat. Also es ist schon ein bisschen durcheinander alles. Und da hat man den Eindruck, ja, oftmals verstehen dann halt die beteiligten Richter solche Sachen auch nicht ganz. Das ist natürlich auch nicht ganz einfach. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt nicht jahrelang mit dem Medium umgeht, wie soll man es dann verstehen?
Ich denke, es ist auch ein Lernprozess, der an der Stelle da im juristischen Bereich einfach einsetzen muss. Das ist insofern schon sehr positiv festzustellen, dass es überhaupt erst mal viele auf das Internet spezialisierte Rechtsanwälte mittlerweile gibt. Viele bloggen ja auch. Es gibt diverse Blogs, die sich ausschließlich um das Jura-Thema kümmern, auch ein Juraviki. Da schaue ich jetzt nicht so häufig rein, auch mit Jura nicht so vertraut. Aber ich denke, dass diese Kultur muss jetzt auch erst mal heranwachsen. Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass solche Rechtsprechungen lange überlebt. Aber es ist natürlich bedenklich, dass es sich überhaupt erst mal so weit entwickelt hat, da das die Nutzung des Internets als freies Kommunikationsmedium doch nachhaltig einschränkt. Wenn man sich überhaupt erst mal, bevor man ein Webforum aufsetzt, darüber Gedanken macht, wie man das ganze 24 Stunden am Tag überwacht. Und wer sagt da irgendwas über Reaktionszeiten aus? Wenn da jetzt einer reinpostet, bis wann muss ich das dann entfernt haben? Innerhalb von 24 Stunden oder innerhalb von 24 Tagen oder 24 Jahren?
Keiner weiß das. Da sind sich die Leute auch alle nicht sehr einig. Letztens habe ich von jemandem gehört, die hat eine Abmahnung gekriegt. Die hat am Sonntag, glaube ich, die Abmahnung bekommen. Und bis Montag 12 Uhr sollte sie einen Text entfernt haben. Es ging jetzt nicht um ein Forum, sondern um etwas anderes. Aber auch um einen Text von einem Dritten. Ja, da hat die keine Zeit, sich einen anwaltlichen Rat zu holen. Das ist einfach eine Frist, die ist nicht wirklich einhaltbar. Man kann natürlich dagegen sagen, dann halte ich die Frist nicht ein, dann klagt der andere, dann kann man sich beschweren, dass die Frist zu knapp war und so weiter. Es gibt natürlich immer wieder die Möglichkeit. Aber es ist auch alles ein finanzielles Risiko. Und viele Anwälte, die sagen, sie seien die großen Internetanwälte, beherrschen auch nicht mehr die Grundlagen. Also hatte ich auch schon, dass ich da seltsame Briefe von Anwälten bekommen habe. Dann musste ich denen erstmal ein paar Sachen erklären. Und dann kam, okay, damit hat sie die Sache erledigt. Also es gibt alles. Wenn man ein paar Projekte hat, wo auch die Nutzer sich daran beteiligen können, dann kann es passieren, dass man schon immer Ärger kriegt, sagen wir mal so. Und das Schöne am Internet ist ja im Augenblick, dass das alte Kommunikationsnetz, was so Mitte der 90er groß war, und die privaten Homepages und der Gedankenaustausch und die Kommunikation, die damals über Mailinglisten hauptsächlich lief, etc.
Und über das Newsnet noch, genau.
Dass es jetzt wieder zurückkommt. Also nachdem jetzt der ganze Hype zusammengebrochen ist, kommt ja jetzt die ganze, mit Blogs, etc., die ganzen Sachen auf. Und das ist schon wieder toll, weil dann wird das Internet als Kommunikationsmedium wieder gesehen. Und wenn da dann ja durch komische Rechtsprechungen eine Verunsicherung herrscht, dann ist das nicht sehr förderlich. Also ich meine, viele haben auch schon ihre Blogs oder ihre Kommentarfunktionen abgeschaltet oder sind einfach dabei, sehr schnell irgendwelche Sachen zu löschen. Weil, kann man ja nachvollziehen im Zweifelsfalle, warum sollte ich den Kopf hinhalten für irgendeinen Kommentar von jemand anderem? Also lösche ich ihn. Und das ist letztendlich schade, weil oftmals ist es nicht so einfach, zu verifizieren, ob dieser Kommentar jetzt tatsächlich eine Rechtsverletzung ist oder ob dieser Kommentar tatsächlich eine Verleumdung von jemand anderem ist und so weiter.
Das geht ja auch noch ein bisschen weiter, wenn man sich mal so ein bisschen darüber nachdenkt, was für technische Antworten man auf das Problem legen könnte. Da hat man jetzt gerade bei Foren, aber auch bei Webblog-Kommentaren natürlich so das Problem, jemand schreibt mir jetzt den Kommentar, es taucht auf meiner Seite auf. Und jetzt gerade nach dieser Heiser-Entscheidung wird diese Aussage, die er da getroffen wird, quasi mir zugeschlagen, obwohl sie ganz jemand anders gemacht hat. Aber eigentlich ist es ja diese Person, von der diese Information kommt.
Ja, also noch nicht. Also die Aussage wird einem noch nicht zugesprochen. Zumindest, sofern man glaubhaft machen kann, dass man nicht selbst diese Person war.
Aber der Fall würde ganz anders liegen, wenn er in seinem Webblog auf meinen Beitrag verweist und ihn eben so kommentiert, dass man nicht einen Kommentar macht, sondern vielleicht ein Trackback.
Zum einen ist es ja schon noch so, dass man zumindest bei der ersten Verletzung in diesem Falle erst darauf hingewiesen werden muss, dass da eine Rechtsverletzung ist und also erst ab Kenntnis haftet. Wenn man natürlich annimmt, man hat Kenntnis oder aus irgendwelchen Gründen dem Betreiber nachgewiesen oder nachgesagt wird, er hätte Kenntnis, dann hat man schlechte Karten. Also wenn man zum Beispiel ein moderiertes Forum hat und in diesem moderierten Forum wird eine unwahre Tatsachenbehauptung aufgestellt. Wenn jemand behauptet, im Laden XYZ hat mich ein Verkäufer übers Ohr gehauen und das zwar relativ glaubhaft darstellt, aber es einfach falsch ist, möglicherweise dann kann das Ärger geben, weil man hat es ja moderiert. Man hat selbst Kenntnis als Betreiber von diesem Beitrag und damit ist man dafür verantwortlich.
Aber bei der Heise Entscheidung ist ja nun genau diese Sache wurde ja nicht gefolgt.
Wobei es erst die zweite Stufe ist. Also wenn man einmal darauf hingewiesen wurde, dass es diese Rechtsverletzung gibt, dann ist es berechtigt in Zukunft zu verlangen, dass sie nicht noch mal auftaucht.
Aber nur diese eine konkrete Verletzung.
Aber trotzdem kann man da ein Geschäftsmodell draus machen. Also ich schreibe unter Pseudonym in einem anderen Forum zum Beispiel eine Beleidigung über mich oder einen Aufruf, meinen Webserver zu attackieren. Schicke dem eine Abmahnung. Er muss die unterschreiben und mir zusichern, dass er dafür Sorge tragen wird, dass er nie mehr erscheint, so in der Art. Und ein paar Tage später schicke ich über einen Anonymisierungsdienst nochmal einen entsprechenden Beitrag bei ihm ins Forum rein und mahne ihn dann wieder ab. Dann habe ich ein gutes Geschäftsmodell, weil dann die Vertragsstrafe fällig wird. Das ist natürlich ein Extrembeispiel und das ist auch ein bisschen übertrieben.
Ich würde das nicht ganz so komplett von der Hand weisen. Also solche Sachen wird da schon drauf kommen. Wir haben das jetzt nicht gesagt.
Solche Geschäftsmodelle kann man sich natürlich überlegen, ob die letztendlich dann auch durchkommen würden vor Gericht und so weiter. Das ist natürlich was anderes, klar.
Ja, aber diese Abmahn-Kultur hat ja nun auch kräftig Aufwind im Internet, gerade in Blogs. Und ich sehe das zumindest mit Bedenken, wie sich das entführt.
Also wenn man jemand an Karren fahren will, dann ist das schon machbar. Im mittleren Aufwand machbar, ja.
Ja, jetzt haben wir diesen Komplex schon ganz gut abgeläutet. Was wollte ich denn gerade noch sagen? Ach ja, genau. Im Prinzip stellen sich ja noch ein paar andere Fragen. Mir fehlt gerade noch diese Sache mit digitaler Identität ein. Also wenn ich jetzt quasi einen Kommentar mache in einem Webblog und wenn man nach einem Weg sucht, wie man, obwohl jemand anders das beiträgt, ihn sozusagen dafür auch zur Verantwortung zieht, dass es sozusagen sein Ding ist, diese Aussage auch wieder zurückzunehmen, bzw. wenn sie da steht, dass es nicht zumindest mir angehaftet wird, stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wie logge ich mich jetzt sozusagen in dieses System ein, um diesen Kommentar überhaupt erst zu hinterlassen. Jedes Webforum hat schon natürlich irgendwie, ich mache mir meinen Account und habe Username und Passwort, das kann ich mir jedes Mal wieder neu ausdenken und ich habe auch überall was anderes. Es gibt jetzt schon erste Ideen für digitale Identitätssysteme, also es gibt viele, auch Microsoft hat es schon mal probiert. Ein Passwort bisher ist halt noch keiner so richtig durchgedrungen und ich halte das Rennen auch für komplett offen, ob sich sowas überhaupt durchsetzen wird. Das wäre aber natürlich auch ein Ansatz zu sagen, okay, wenn ich jetzt auf meinem Webforum nur noch Leute in ihrer vollen Identität abgesichert durch irgendwelche Zertifikate, die von irgendeiner Zertifikatsautorität unterschrieben sind und so ist ja nicht komplett von der Hand zu weisen, dass solche Systeme demnächst auch mal funktionieren könnten, dann könnte ich sozusagen die Verantwortung abschieben. Da hätte man im Prinzip ja auch wiederum mehr Verantwortung zur eigenen Aussage.
Ja, so hat das Gericht ja auch im Heisefall ja argumentiert. Ich meine, wenn Sie das nicht selbst überwachen können, dann dürfen Sie halt nur noch Benutzer schreiben lassen, die Ihnen persönlich quasi mit Namen und Ansprüchen bekannt sind, also Postidentverfahren oder irgendwas, was halt in der Erotikbranche genutzt wird, um die Altersverifikation durchzuführen. Also da könnte man natürlich solche Möglichkeiten nutzen. Nur das würde natürlich die gesamte Kommunikation kaputt machen. Weil wenn ich irgendwo mal einen Kommentar hinterlassen will, dann registriere ich mich doch nicht erst per Post und per Postidentverfahren da, um irgendwo einen Kommentar abzulassen. Dann lasse ich es halt sein.
Genau. Und weg ist die Kommunikation.
Und vielleicht würde man dann auch sich selbst wieder zensieren und eine Sache, die man halt sonst nicht schreiben würde, dann doch weglassen und so weiter. Deswegen gibt es ja auch das Recht, dass man anonym oder pseudonym sich zu Wort melden kann. Und das, vom Gedanken her, vom Grundgesetz und auch wie es das Bundesverfassungsgericht immer wieder formuliert hat, ist es ja auch sehr vernünftig. Man will die Meinungsbildung fördern und man soll das Recht haben, sich öffentlich zu äußern. Und es soll niemand die Angst haben, dass er möglicherweise irgendetwas sagt, was irgendwelchen Machthabern oder Wirtschaftsinteressen widerspricht.
Das wird natürlich zerstört in dem Moment, wo man die Möglichkeit zu dieser Anonymität oder Pseudonymität verliert, in dem man halt eine Anmeldezwange hat.
Ja und vor allen Dingen in dem Augenblick, wo jeder Angst hat, dass seine Aussage vielleicht irgendwas was Unrechtmäßiges ist. Ich meine, natürlich muss man auch umgekehrt darauf achten, dass es durchaus auch Fälle gibt, wo jemand zu Recht eine Rechtsverletzung bemängelt. Man muss natürlich immer zwei Seiten sehen. Derjenige, dessen Rechte verletzt wurden, der möchte natürlich auch, dass das wieder aufgehoben wird, die Verletzung, oder dass es erst gar nicht passiert und so weiter. Also es ist schwierig, eine Balance zu finden, das ist ganz klar. Aber im Augenblick sieht es wieder so aus, als ob die Balance zu Ungunsten der Internetnutzer und zu Ungunsten der Betreiber von entsprechenden Diensten ausgelegt wird. Und das kann es natürlich nicht sein. Also jemand, dessen Rechte verletzt wurden, der muss es natürlich nachweisen. Und er muss denjenigen angreifen, der der tatsächliche Verletzer ist.
So, jetzt wollte ich nochmal zurückkommen auf den Anfang unseres Gesprächs, was ja hier ein Workshop gemacht ist, auf den Datenspuren hier in Dresden zum Telemediengesetz. Dabei handelt es sich um ein Gesetz, das es noch nicht gibt, aber was es geben soll. Kannst du da vielleicht mal so kurz umreißen, was Inhalt dieses Gesetzes ist, was es vielleicht ersetzt oder ergänzt?
Ja, also das Telemediengesetz ist quasi das Zusammenwerfen von dem Teledienstegesetz und dem Mediendienststaatsvertrag sowie dem Teledienste-Datenschutzgesetz. Diese drei Gesetze zusammen regeln im Augenblick den Umgang im Internet, kann man mal so grob sagen. Das Teledienstegesetz ist halt dafür verantwortlich, welche Pflichten ein Shopbetreiber zum Beispiel hat und welche Rechte man da hat und welche Rahmenbedingungen da gesetzt sind. Der Mediendienststaatsvertrag ist hauptsächlich für meinungsbildende Medien zuständig. Also eher die Richtung Grundfunk und Presse wird auch deswegen von den Ländern. Ja, ist ein Staatsvertrag zwischen den Ländern. Und das Teledienste-Datenschutzgesetz ist für die Datenschutzbelange zuständig. Also das besagt, welche Daten ein Dienstebetreiber denn erheben darf und wie er die verarbeiten darf, wann er die löschen muss und so weiter. Und diese drei werden quasi zusammengesetzt zum neuen Telemediengesetz. Ein bisschen teilgeht auch noch ein Rundfunkstaatsvertrag wieder raus. Und es ist ein bisschen das ganze Kuddelmuddel, was es gab seit 1998, als die Gesetze gebaut wurden, zwischen Bund und Ländern, die Kompetenzaufteilung und drei Gesetze, wird jetzt alles ein bisschen vereinheitlicht und geht jetzt im Wesentlichen zum Bund die Kompetenz über und wird in einem Gesetz vereinheitlicht.
Dein Workshop ging jetzt ein bisschen darum, es gibt ja auch die Möglichkeit Alphos zu nehmen, weil es ist ja noch nicht verabschiedet. Dein Ansatz war sozusagen, was sind unsere Vorstellungen jetzt als erfahrene Internetbenutzer, wie man da vorgehen kann. Kannst du da vielleicht mal so zwei, drei Thesen, die sich jetzt aus dem ersten Workshop-Tag vielleicht auch schon ergeben haben, mal mit einbringen, was an der Stelle da…
Also ein wichtiger Punkt ist natürlich die Haftungsfrage. Da haben wir heute auch ausgiebig darüber diskutiert. Wann soll ein Betreiber oder ein Hostprovider verantwortlich sein für Inhalte von Dritten, beziehungsweise soll er überhaupt verantwortlich sein? Und die Linkfrage und so weiter. Und da ist natürlich ganz klar, erstmal kann man nicht für Inhalte von anderen Personen haftbar sein. Sofern man nicht selbst… Es ist nicht naheliegend, dass man die selbst ist, ist es klar, aber man ist nicht dafür verantwortlich, was andere machen. Dann ist aber halt die Frage, wie schaut es aus, wenn ich jetzt die Meldung kriege, da ist aber ein Inhalt bei dir im Forum zum Beispiel, der verletzt meine Rechte, weil der beleidigt mich oder der behauptet eine falsche Tatsache über mich. Und wie ist damit umzugehen? Weil ich meine, es gibt natürlich diverse Abstufungen von so einem System. Die Frage, ist das wirklich eine Beleidigung, ist das wirklich eine falsche Tatsachenbehauptung? Wen sollte man denn angehen? Zum Beispiel gab es auch zeitweise, ich glaube, es wurde vor allen Dingen in Großbritannien praktiziert, die Aktion, dass gegen unliebsame Webseiten vorgegangen wurde, indem deren Hosting-Provider einen Brief bekam, hier, wir weisen sie darauf hin, dass da unsere Rechte verletzt werden und machen sie das sofort dicht, sonst verklagen wir sie. Und das kann natürlich nicht sein, dass man jemand Drittes haftbar macht, wenn der eigentliche vermeintliche Störer oder Urheber der schädigenden Inhalte greifbar ist, wenn er namentlich bekannt ist. Also es ist natürlich auch klar, solange jemand bekannt ist, der einen entsprechenden rechtswidrigen Inhalt irgendwo geschrieben hat, dann muss der angegangen werden. Also nicht der Ausdien-Provider, sondern dessen Kunde, der in der Regel ja bekannt ist. Bei Foren kann es natürlich auch wieder kompliziert sein, wenn man keine Anmeldungen braucht oder wenn die Anmeldungen unter Pseudonym möglich ist. Da gibt es natürlich viele Sonderfälle, wo mal die eine, mal die andere Seite recht haben kann. Und man möchte natürlich nicht, dass da irgendwelche grundsätzlichen Probleme auftauchen. Auf der einen Seite nicht, dass Beleidigungen komplett unverfolgbar sind und an der Tagesordnung werden. Und zum anderen aber auch nicht, dass jetzt irgendwelche Forenbetreiber über Gebühr für fremde Inhalte gerade zu stehen haben. Und da muss man natürlich eine Balance finden. Und da haben wir ja sehr lange diskutiert, verschiedene Ideen entwickelt. Und da müssen wir morgen mal ein bisschen gucken, wie man da was machen kann.
Sammelst du das irgendwie in irgendeiner Form ein?
Ja, also ich habe vor, zu dem Thema Telemediengesetz eine größere Aktion zu machen. Auch wenn es klappt, eine Kampagne. Im Idealfall wäre natürlich ganz toll, einen eigenen Gesetzentwurf einzubringen. Das Gesetzgebungsverfahren ist da schon sehr weit fortgeschritten. Aber es ist bisher außerhalb des parlamentarischen Raumes. Also von den Staatssekretären wurde das gebaut und nicht von Parlamentariern, also nicht von den Abgeordneten. Und von daher hat man noch sehr viele Möglichkeiten, Einfluss zu nehmen. Den kann man natürlich nutzen. Das ist natürlich auch eine Zeitfrage. Klar, das muss irgendwie gemacht werden. Und wenn man eine Kampagne macht, ist auch eine finanzielle Frage, wie man das dann umsetzt. Aber im Idealfall gibt es dann vielleicht mal einen Gesetzesentwurf. Ja, das ist sehr optimistisch. Aber zumindest Vorschläge, wie denn die Sachen geregelt sein sollten. Und konkrete Änderungsvorschläge am aktuellen Entwurf. Also es gibt auch schon Erfolge, muss ich sagen. Also im Mai letzten Jahres gab es eine Anhörung im Wirtschaftsministerium. Und da waren hauptsächlich Industrievertreter da. Und relevante Ansprechpartner für das Internet, nämlich ARD und ZDF, die Datenschutzbeauftragten von ARD und ZDF, der Bund der Zeitungsverleger, der Kabelverband und diverse andere Firmen, die alle sehr relevant sind für das Internet, wie wir hören. Es waren allerdings auch eBay und T-Online vertreten, aber die Mehrheit kam wirklich aus dem Rundfunkbereich, der Verband der privaten Rundfunkbetreiber und so weiter. Und als einzige Nichtwirtschaftsinteressenvertreter war der Mensch von der Verbraucherzentrale und ich da und sonst nur.
Weil die jetzt mehr eingeladen wurden oder sich nicht genug gemeldet haben?
Also ich weiß nicht, ob der Verbraucherzentrale eingeladen wurde. Ich wurde auch nicht eingeladen und habe es halt mitgekriegt und habe mich darum gekümmert, dass ich noch nachträglich quasi eine Einladung kriege.
Aber die Einladung hing wahrscheinlich mehrere Monate auf Ursa, Minor Beta aus.
Ja gut, es ist natürlich so, man muss sich als Organisation registrieren und die registrierten Organisationen kriegen dann Einladungen, aber auch nur unter bestimmten Bedingungen. Und wenn sie so und so viele Jahre schon registriert sind, teilweise, ich weiß nicht, wie es in diesem konkreten Fall ist. Also im Idealfall werden die betroffenen Parteien, wie es heißt, rechtzeitig informiert und können auch eine schriftliche Stellungnahme abgeben und können die auch nochmal mündlich dann zehn Minuten was sagen. Aber gut, ich speziell hatte halt ein paar Tage vorher erfahren und klar, da brauchen wir natürlich selbst auch entsprechende Manpower, um überhaupt eine Infrastruktur zu haben, die solche Veranstaltungen, die es immer wieder mal gibt, zu überwachen und zu gucken, was man da machen kann, wo man selbst aktiv werden muss und so weiter. Und naja, gut, ich hatte halt dann das Glück, da noch teilnehmen zu können und es war natürlich sehr interessant, wie dann die einzelnen Standpunkte sind. Und es gibt natürlich alles Partikularinteressen, die die vertreten. Das ist ja auch ihr gutes Recht. Nur ist es natürlich schade, dass von den Nutzern und von der Netzgemeinschaft selbst wenig kommt. Weil man hat natürlich auch nicht die finanziellen Mittel. Ich meine, klar, die einzelnen Verbände, die finanzieren sich von den Mitgliedsbeiträgen der Wirtschaftsunternehmen und die haben dann entsprechende Mittel. Und da haben wir natürlich jetzt nicht so viel entgegenzusetzen. Und das ist immer natürlich sehr schwierig da irgendwas.
Ja, aber ich denke, das ist auch generell ein, wie soll ich sagen? Ich glaube, dass es auch vielen Leuten nicht klar ist, dass man tatsächlich auf der Ebene auch wirklich die Möglichkeit hat, Einfluss zu nehmen. Viele Gesetze werden halt einfach immer so, oh Gott, da kommt jetzt wieder dieses Gesetz und sie, da oben, wie auch immer man das nennt, die beschließen das jetzt wieder und wir haben ja irgendwie keine Chance, blablabla. Dann regt man sich ein bisschen auf und schimpft im Webblogs und so. Aber eigentlich stellt sich auch die Frage, wie kann man jetzt wirklich mal ganz konkret auch was tun? Und das ist in gewisser Hinsicht einfacher, wie deine Erfahrungen da sind. Aber wenn man halt vor allem erst mal zur Bundestagsanhörung hingeht, selber einen Eindruck davon bekommt, wer da jetzt eigentlich irgendwie diskutiert und noch feststellt, dass da teilweise so dermaßen am Thema vorbei diskutiert wird von Leuten, die da eigentlich gar nichts zu sagen haben, dass man sich in dem Moment einfach einmischt und auch wirklich mal den Schritt nach vorne macht und langsam erlernt, wie diese Prozesse ablaufen, um da Einfluss nehmen zu können.
Ja, also das Schimpfen über die da oben ist natürlich immer einfach. Aber ich habe jetzt nicht den Eindruck, dass da jemand vorhat, einen übers Ohr zu hauen oder sowas, sondern es geht schon darum, gute Gesetze zu machen, in den meisten Fällen. Manchmal ist natürlich auch immer irgendwelche Spezialinteressen vorhanden, aber in der Regel geht es schon darum, ordentliche Sachen zu machen. Aber ja, wie sollen sie denn reagieren, wenn sie nur die Informationen von Ebay und Co. kriegen, die ihre Lobbyarbeit machen?
Sie sind halt einfach überhaupt nicht in der Lage, das einzuschätzen, weil sie nur die falschen Informationen gesteckt bekommen.
Und ich denke, ein Erfolg ist sicherlich, dass die Impressumspflicht ein bisschen eingeschränkt ist im aktuellen Entwurf. Der Entwurf damals, vom Mai, der noch aktuell war, sah eine seriide Impressumspflicht vor. Also sah vor, dass im Prinzip jede Webseite Name und Anschrift des Verantwortlichen enthält. Und die Webseiten, die im geschäftlichen Umfeld tätig sind, sind zusätzlich noch weitere Angaben enthalten müssen. Das ist jetzt in der Zwischenzeit abgeschwächt. Dass nur noch Webseiten, die in entsprechenden gewerblichen geschäftlichen Umfeldern tätig sind, so ist der aktuelle Entwurf, und in der Regel zum Geldverdienen so ungefähr formuliert, da sind, dass dann die Angaben da sein müssen. Was ja auch okay ist, natürlich möchte ich, dass jeder Online-Shop und jeder, der weiß gar ja, was macht, ein anständiges Impressum hat, wo man sich hier hinwenden kann mit Telefonnummern und so weiter.
Dass man einfach auch weiß, mit wem man es zu tun hat.
Genau, aber Tante Trude, die jetzt ihre Urlaubsbilder von letzten Kreuzfahrt irgendwie ins Netz stellt für ihre fünf Freundinnen.
Oder Webblogs, denkt ja nur an diese ganzen erotischen, anonymen Webblogs, wo der Inhalt kein Problem ist, aber der ansonsten nie der Öffentlichkeit erblicken würde, wenn die Leute wirklich dazu gezwungen würden, zu sagen, wer sie sind.
Genau, oder irgendwelche Frauen, die Angst haben, dass sie irgendwie belästigt werden, wenn sie ihre Telefonnummer angeben müssen. Und das wurde jetzt dann doch deutlich entschärft, soweit ich das verstanden habe. Und da ist dem Gesetzgeber, den Staatssekretären auch bewusst geworden, okay, da ist ein Problem. Wir wollen natürlich nicht das privaten Homepage betreiben, was ich jetzt auch im Kommentar, dass die Namen und Anschrift angeben müssen, sondern natürlich die gewerblichen, da ist das auch vollkommen richtig, aber bei den privaten da macht man Ausnahmen und die bleiben dann davon verschont. Man ist natürlich auch immer eine Frage, wann ist es gewerblich und wann ist es geschäftlich. Es ist nicht immer so einfach, aber zumindest ist es doch deutlich entschärft worden. Und letztendlich, wenn es wirkliche Rechtsverletzung irgendwo gibt, dann kommt man ja trotzdem an die Daten dran. Und einen Betreiber gibt es immer. Die Webseiber stehen ja nicht irgendwo im luftleeren Raum, sondern die sind da und es ist immer jemand erreichbar, der dafür verantwortlich ist. Und von daher ist die Problematik da auch nicht gegeben. Aber wenn natürlich Tante Trude, vor allen Dingen ist es ja auch so, dass das mit dem neuen Entwurf eine Ordnungswidrigkeit ist. Das heißt, von Behörden kann dann ein Ordnungsgeld verhängt werden, was bisher nicht der Fall war. Da kann der Konkurrent abmahnen lassen oder ein Verbraucherschutzverband abmahnen. Aber nicht die Aufsichtsbehörde kann ein Ordnungsgeld verhängen. Und es ist jetzt im neuen Entwurf zusätzlich vorgesehen, dass ein Ordnungsgeld verhängt werden kann. Und dann hat natürlich Tante Trude ein Problem, wenn sie eine Impression bräuchte und nur mal kurz ihre Urlaubsfotos ins Netz stellt. Von daher ist es eine sehr sinnvolle Änderung. Und ich denke, der Auftritt in der Anhörung hat da geholfen.
Ja, also um es mal zusammenzufassen, es ist durchaus so, dass man was bewegen kann. Ich kann auch feststellen, dass so eigentlich auch in der Internet-Szene mittlerweile so ein bisschen der Weckruf auch eingesetzt hat, dass Leute begreifen, dass wenn man jetzt noch weiter stillsteht, dass all das, was man jetzt beklagt hat in den letzten Jahren an negativen Entwicklungen, dass das nur so weitergeht, wenn man sich halt nicht wirklich konkret einmischt und nicht einfach nur rumschimpft, sondern auch mal versucht, konkret zu checken, was geht wirklich, wenn ihr in Berlin wohnt irgendwie. Der Bundestag steht vor einer Tür, wenn ihr in der Nähe von anderen Landeshauptstädten wohnt. Auch da kann man natürlich Einfluss nehmen. Es gibt den Abgeordneten, der für den eigenen Wahlbezirk zuständig ist zum Beispiel.
Genau, man kann immer seinem lokalen Abgeordneten schreiben. Man kann auch einen Termin machen, sich mit ihm im Büro treffen.
Ja, mit denen ist es wahrscheinlich genauso wie mit Podcastern. Die freuen sich über jede Meinungsbildung, die dann an einen herangetragen wird. Ich will nicht sagen, dass jetzt alle ein offenes Ohr haben, aber ich will auch genauso wenig behaupten, dass sie das nicht haben, weil teilweise sind sie halt einfach nur hilflos und sind gar nicht böse und haben einfach die falschen Informationen. Und wenn man sie nicht präsentiert, darf man sich danach auch immer nicht beschweren. Schon gar nicht mit dem Argument, wir haben es euch ja gleich gesagt, weil man hat es ihnen halt gar nicht gesagt.
Und natürlich sind die Themen oft komplexer, muss ich selbst sehr viele Gedanken machen, wie man denn ein Thema rüberbringt. Man kann das dann vollkommen falsch machen, auch wenn man es gut meint. Also es ist nicht immer einfach. Also auch das, was wir jetzt hier erzählt haben, hoffe ich, war verständlich. Das kann natürlich auch sein, wenn es jetzt ein Politiker hört, dass er denkt, die sind ja total verrückt. Also wie gesagt, nach meiner Erfahrung meint es keiner wirklich böse mit einem. Im schlimmsten Falle ist jemand vielleicht ein bisschen dumm oder naiv. Oder, ja gut, es kommt auch mal vor, dass jemand natürlich handfeste Interessen vertritt. Aber naja, gut, okay, damit kann man auch umgehen. Und dann muss man sich jetzt an andere Personen wenden.
Ja, Alvar, das war unsere 85-Minuten-Folge.
Quatsch, Greg.
Ja, von wegen halbe Stunde. Das Thema war viel zu interessant, aber ich fand es super. Das war ein schöner Roundup. Und mit der Bitte der Beteiligung an politischen Prozessen, glaube ich, können wir unsere Hörer jetzt hier auch zurücklassen. Es ist auf jeden Fall möglich, wenn ihr Interesse habt an den Ergebnissen der Datenspuren. Wir werden Aufzeichnungen der Vorträge veröffentlichen. Jetzt sein Workshop ist, glaube ich, nicht aufgezeichnet worden.
Aber wir werden sicherlich auch ein bisschen Material haben.
Es wird sich sicherlich was im Netz finden lassen, auf jeden Fall bei odem.org. Und natürlich werden wir, wenn es weitere interessante Bewegungen gibt, auch versuchen, bei Chaosradio diese Thematik nochmal aufzugreifen. Ich glaube, Telemediengesetz ist da definitiv ein Thema, was wir in diesem Jahr nochmal angehen sollten, weil es, wie gesagt, 2007 dann in die Umsetzung kommen soll. Und wir wollen natürlich dazu beitragen, dass hier die Informationen frei fließen. So, jetzt haben wir fleißig gelinkt und referenziert. Und damit lassen wir euch alleine das Gewummer von der Party hier unten, das greift jetzt hier auch langsam auf den Raum über. Und insofern bleibt mir nichts weiter übrig, als Tschüss zu sagen. Und wir hören uns bald wieder beim Chaosradio Express.